♪♪♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to "Corrections,"
our digital-only --
digital-only effort
to make sure we correct
everything that we got wrong
this week,
because our goal each
and every week at "Late Night"
is to be perfect.
I said the word code-ified
It's cod-ified.
Thank you to our viewers
for pointing that out.
I said, "The Prime Ministe
of Ireland."
I was told it's called
the Taoiseach. [taysha]
I'm still going to say
prime minister.
Also, based on the way
"Taoiseach" is spelled,
I would have thought
it was "Tao is each."
I think you know --
I think our Irish viewers know
I wasn't going to say Taoiseach.
I think you were just --
just having a crack.
They'll know what that means
Oh, this is interesting.
In a "Closer Look,"
we had a joke
about a 1986 Camaro,
so then we go
to a photo service
and we ask them to get us
a 1986 Camaro.
And then during rehearsals
someone in the crew said
that's not a Camaro.
That's a Pontiac Trans Am.
And so we called the photo
service back and they said
no, that's definitely --
definitely a Camaro.
So then we put it in the show,
and a bunch of you said
that is a Pontiac Trans Am
So, long story short,
we have stopped using
Giuliani Photo Service.
[ Laughter ]
Last night,
we had a joke about Nic Cage
where I said, as Nic Cage,
that I had --
my parents were velociraptor
who put me up for adoption
And then we showed
the adoption papers.
And it said "child's name
prior to adoption."
It said "Nic Cage."
And someone said,
"Hey, man, you know better
You know Nic Cage
isn't his real name."
Because he's Nicolas Coppola
But I would like to point ou
that in this world we buil
his dinosaur name is Nic Cage,
then he was adopted
by the Coppolas,
and then when he went
into show business,
he went back
to his dinosaur name.
That transitions well
into dragons.
This is a correction that I go
based on a correction.
I corrected my pronunciation
of the J.R.R. Tolkien dragon
And I know it's "Tol-keen.
Just wanted to see how fas
you ran to your keyboards.
[ Laughter ]
I said it was Smog,
and then I was told
it was Smaug.
And I said, "I'm sorry
I got the name of the dragon
from 'Lord of the Rings' wrong."
And then people said,
"He's from 'The Hobbit.'"
But now I think I'm ready
to do a Q&A
at a "Lord of the Rings"
convention.
And it's a bummer for me
because "The Hobbit"
is my favorite
of all those books,
'cause it's, uh, the shortest.
[ Laughter ]
I don't --
I don't want to judge this
but, again, I like --
I like nerdy stuff.
This is not me being like,
"Oh, it's..."
I just think I read it --
They just went over my head.
I just think I read it
when I was too young.
I was like 30.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, I like "The Hobbit"
because --
I mean, with all due respect
to, like, Frodo and Samwise,
is my favorite hobbit, has
always -- always been Dildo.
[ Laughter ]
This isn't a correction.
This is something I got right.
Which is that
Benjamin Franklin's wife's nam
was Deborah.
But then I comment on the fact
that Deborah, to me,
seems just like a modern name.
I was very surprised
that Benjamin Franklin's wif
was Deborah.
And then a bunch of people
pointed out to me
that Deborah is actually
in the Old Testament.
Which is just shocking to me
Now, again, I don't --
I'm not a Bible reader.
You know, I'd read it
if the other option
was, like,
"Return of the King."
[ Laughter ]
But, like, Deborah --
I can't believe
Deborah is
an Old Testament name.
It'd be like if you told m
Noah's --
Noah's wife was, like, Patty
[ Laughter ]
"Abraham. They want Abraha
to kill his son.
Can you believe
he has to tell Candace?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, um...
Amber's is still wrong
about "crikey"
being a thing that people
in New Zealand say.
And she was
standing by it, right?
-I'm not wrong.
I'm 100-percent right.
Anyone who says I'm wrong
is also wrong.
Also, Seth really told me
not to tell that joke,
and then I told it anyway.
[ Laughter ]
-Also last week, I --
I yelled at Amber,
"I can't hear you
through your mask."
And a few people said,
"Uh, it's a face shield."
-Oh, yuck.
Seth, all of this is bad.
Don't do this.
Don't talk to these people
-And I'm just saying, guys
like, I know everything
you nitpick,
I then make time for
and draw attention to it,
in a way almost rewarding you.
But you've got to stop!
'Cause I can't.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I think that's
another A-plus for us.
[ Laughter ]
Now, "Corrections" is over
but we're gonna --
We're gonna run this
YouTube video another hour
[ Laughter ]
Isn't this a little bit...
more exciting than
"Lord of the Rings"?
[ Laughter ]
Get outta here!